G
A PARTICULARLY POWERFUL --
WITH NIGERIA'S YOUNGEST VOTERS.
>> THESE ARE --
HIS A WEALTHY BUSINESSMAN WITH
A PENNY PINCHING REPUTATION.
HE'S SHAKING UP THE NIGERIAN
ELECTORATE.
HE TAKES ON TO POLITICAL
HEAVYWEIGHTS, AHEAD OF THE 2023
ELECTIONS.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY SAY
THEY'RE DESPERATE FOR GOOD
GOVERNMENTS, AMID CONCERNS FOR
HIGH INFLATION, A DEPRECIATED
LOCKER CURRENCY, AND KIDNAPPING
FOR RANSOM.
61-YEAR-OLD, PEWTER O B,
APPEARS TO BE A MESSIAH OF
SORTS.
THIS GENERATION AGED 23 AND
BELOW WHO MAKE UP 30% OF THE
POPULATION, ACCORDING TO THE
UNITED NATIONS POPULATION
FUNDS.
THIS MAN IS 24, HE IS ONE OF
THE ORGANIZERS OF A MOVEMENT
SUPPORTING OBI, KNOWN AS
OBEDIENCE.
>> THE OBEAH MOVEMENT IS PRETTY
SIMPLE.
WE ARE JUST A GROUP OF
FRUSTRATING NIGERIANS WHO WANT
GOOD GOVERNANCE.
IT'S A SIMPLE AS THAT.
WE ARE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENCY,
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF US, IN
THE OBEDIENT MOVEMENTS.
WE ARE RUNNING FOR --
THROUGH PETER OB OBI >> HE'S
SEEN AS A CREDIBLE ALTERNATIVE
TO THE TWO PARTIES THAT HAVE
DOMINATED POLITICS SINCE THE
END OF MILITARY RULE IN 1999.
ALTHOUGH HIS OFFSHORE ACCOUNTS
WERE AMONG THOSE FOUND IN A
LEAKED PANDORA PAPER WHICH
EXPOSED THE HIDDEN RICHES OF
THE GLOBAL ELITE IN 2021.
OBI DENIES ANY WRONGDOING.
THE OBEDIENCE MOVEMENT IS
POWERED BY SOCIAL MEDIA, AND
SIMILAR TO THE --
PROTEST, ALSO NICKNAMED --
SPEAK OFF AGAINST POLICE
BRUTALITY IN OCTOBER 2020.
>> WHAT ARE THE SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THE MOVEMENT, AND THE
OBEDIENT MOVEMENT.
THAT'S JUST WHAT STARTED ALL OF
THIS, WE HARNESS THAT PAIN,
THAT ENERGY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LET THIS DAY.
IT'S JUST THE CONTINUATION.
IT'S NOT EVEN --
DEFINITELY PETER OBI IS THE
POSTER CHILD FOR GOOD
GOVERNANCE, BUT IT'S ABOUT US
NIGERIANS.
WHEN WE START TO SPEAK UP FOR
OURSELVES?
>> WITH THE ELECTIONS A FEW
MONTHS AWAY, CRITICS SAY HIS
LABOR PARTY LACKS THE POLITICAL
STRUCTURE NEEDED TO ELECTION.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, THE
OBEDIENCE MOVEMENT CONTINUES TO
GATHER PACE AND GAIN MOMENTUM.
STEPHANIE BUSARI, CNN, LAGOS.
IT
TIME NOW FOR THE EXCHANGE, I
SAT DOWN WITH NIGERIAN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE PETER
OB.
>> MR. OBI THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US.
YOU'RE CERTAINLY THE MOST
POPULAR PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE IN NIGERIA,
THERE'S SO MUCH MOMENTUM BEHIND
YOU.
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
NIGERIANS ARE USED TO BEING
DISAPPOINTED BY THEIR LEADERS,
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
FACING THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW,
THEY ARE SYSTEMIC.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
CORRUPTION, I'M TALKING ABOUT
OIL THEFT, I'M TALKING ABOUT IN
SECURITY, I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
FISCAL HOLE THAT NIGERIA IS IN
RIGHT NOW.
CAN ALL OF THAT REALLY BE
SOLVED BY ONE PERSON?
>> WELL, IF YOU HAVE A LEADER
THAT IS COMPETENT, HAS THE
CAPACITY AND COMMITMENT TO
START DEALING WITH IT, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO SOLVE IT OVERNIGHT.
BUT THERE WILL BE A CLEAR,
VISIBLE, MEASURABLE ATTEMPT TO
DEAL WITH THIS.
AND THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
NOT SOLVE-ABLE, THERE ARE
THINGS THAT CAN BE DEALT WITH
DECISIVELY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LEADER
THAT IS LOOKING AT WHAT WAS
ABLE TO DO IN THE PAST.
YOU CAN SAY YES, --
>> IF YOU DO INDEED BECOME
NIGERIANS NEXT PRESIDENT, NADIR
YOU KNOW, IS BROKE, IT'S BARELY
ABLE TO SERVICE ITS DEBTS.
IT SPENDS SO MUCH MORE THAT IT
EARNS.
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS, FROM A
CONCRETE PERSPECTIVE, WHAT ARE
YOUR PLANS TO TAKE NIGERIA'S
ECONOMY OFF OF LIFE SUPPORT?
>> WELL, A VARIETY OF THINGS.
ONE, IS THAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL
DECISIVELY WITH THE ISSUE OF
SECURITY.
IT'S IMPACTING NEGATIVELY ON
YOUR ECONOMY.
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT HEAD
ON.
YOU HAVE TO GET YOUR FINANCE --
AND START ENSURING THAT THE
VAST LANDS OF THE NORTH IS
INVESTED.
WE HAVE TO START PULLING PEOPLE
OUT OF POVERTY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU HAVE TO REDUCE AGGRESSIVELY,
THE COST OF GOVERNANCE, AND THE
ISSUE OF CORRUPTION.
>> ANYONE WHO KNOWS ANYTHING
ABOUT NIGERIA KNOWS THAT IT HAS
THIS EMBARRASSING REPUTATION OF,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT IT'S
AFRICA'S LARGEST OIL PRODUCER,
IMPORTS REFINED FUEL.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN FOR
TRANSFORMING NIGERIA'S ECONOMY
FROM A CONSUMPTION ECONOMY TO A
PRODUCTION ECONOMY?
>> LET ME TELL YOU IT'S NOT THE
ISSUE I OR REFINERIES CANNOT
WORK --
THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE SHOULD
NOT ENCOURAGE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO OPERATE REFINERIES.
IT CAN BE DONE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, YOU CAN USE TODAY,
DECIDE TO REMOVE THE SUBSIDIES,
USE THE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
PRINCIPAL AREAS OF PRODUCTION
FROM CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO
EDUCATION, TO SUPPORTING
INVESTMENT IN REFINERY, WHICH
WILL BE, DONE IN THE SHORTEST
AMOUNT OF TIME.
>> A LOT OF NIGERIAN PRESIDENTS
HAVE COME IN AND TALKED ABOUT
REVITALIZING THE MANUFACTURING
SECTOR, INVESTING IN REFINERIES,
BUT CHANGE, AS YOU KNOW, HAS
BEEN VERY, VERY SLOW.
WHY IS IT GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
WITH YOU AND WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
WHERE THE BIGGEST HURDLES IN
MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU JUST LISTED
COME TO PASS?
>> WELL, BUT PEOPLE NEED TO DO
IS LOOK AT WHAT IS PROMISED AT
THE STATE GOVERNOR --
WHEN I SAID I'M GOING TO TURN
AROUND EDUCATION, HEALTH, PULL
PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY --
POVERTY, BRING SANITY
INCIVILITY GOVERNANCE --
TO THAT HAPPEN OR NOT?
WHEN I SAID WE WERE GOING TO
SAVE MONEY, CAN WE DO THAT?
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT ONE OF
THE MAJOR ISSUES THAT NIGERIA
IS DEALING WITH, GRAPPLING WITH
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S VIOLENCE AND INSECURITY.
YOU CAN BARELY TRAVEL FROM ONE
PART OF NIGERIA TO ANOTHER
WITHOUT FEARING FOR YOUR LIFE.
AND TALKING ABOUT KIDNAPPING,
AND TALKING ABOUT BANDITRY, AND
TALKING ABOUT TERRORISM, I'M
TALKING ABOUT BOKO HARAM.
WHAT IS YOUR PLAN FOR THAT?
>> INITIALLY, WHAT WE FIRST
HAVE TO DO IS THE ISSUE OF
SECURITY.
UNLESS YOU HAVE SECURITY, THE
FARMERS CAN'T --
YOU CAN'T HAVE INVESTMENT.
NOBODY WILL EVER WANT TO PUT
MONEY IN US IN SECURE PLACE.
YOU CAN DEAL WITH THAT.
THERE ARE SO MANY --
YOU NEED TO DO A LOT OF WORK,
REORGANIZE YOUR SECURITY
ARCHITECTURE, AND SHOW THAT THE
MULTI LEVEL ISSUE OF THE POLICE
HAVE TO BE DECISIVE AND DEALT
WITH.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS YOU NEED
TO DO.
YOU NEED TO BRING IN WORKERS
INTO THE SECURITY SYSTEM, AND
FEED THEM PROPERLY, HELP THEM
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF
SECURITY.
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT NIGERIA NEEDS.
TODAY >> UNITER ARE BOTH
NIGERIANS, WERE BOTH A BOSE,
WERE FROM SOUTHEASTERN NIGERIA.
IT'S A VERY HARD COUNTRY TO
HOLD TOGETHER.
YOU HAVE TOO MANY TURNING 50
MILLION PEOPLE, SO MANY
DIFFERENT TRIBES, SO MANY
DIFFERENT IDEAS.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE FROM THE SOUTHEAST,
HOW EASY IS IT GOING TO BE TO
RALLY NIGERIANS FROM THE NORTH
BEHIND YOU?
THAT'S GOT TO BE ON YOUR MIND?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT WAS
YESTERDAY.
ANOTHER PROBLEM.
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO BE
ELECTABLE BASED ON ETHNICITY,
RELIGION, MY STRONG CONNECTION
--
FROM ONE --
OR THE OTHER, WHICH BROUGHT US
TO WHERE WE ARE, OUR STRUCTURE,
THE STRUCTURE OF CRIMINALITY,
THAT IS WHAT WE WANT TO
DISMANTLE NOW.
AND ENSURE THAT THE NEXT
SELECTION IS BASED ON CHARACTER,
CAPACITY, COMPETENCE,
COMMITMENT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
NIGERIA NOT JUST IN A PHYSICAL
MESS, IT IS AT THE LAST STAGE
TO COLLAPSE.
THE PEOPLE IN THE NORTH DON'T
HAVE A SECURE PLACE, THEY DON'T
HAVE GOOD ROADS.
THEY DON'T HAVE --
PEOPLE IN THE SOUTH, SOUTHEAST,
THE PEOPLE IN THE SOUTH, ALL
YOU HEAR ABOUT THE ETHNICITIES
--
RELIGION, CONNECTION, IS A
CONSPIRACY TO KEEP NIGERIA
UNDEVELOPED.
BUT NOW WE'VE REACHED THE EDGE.
WE CAN NO LONGER CONTINUE THIS
WAY.